فبراير المسلسل الكويتي الصفقه واللي من
بدايه عرضهم حقق نجاح كبير وتفاعل جميل من
الجمهور المتابع للمسلسل المسلسل من وقت
طرحه متصدر قوائم الاكثر مشاهده خليجيا
وعربيا فهو في المركز الاول من ضمن
المسلسلات الاكثر مشاهده في الكويت من
اسبوعين لليوم وكمان متصدر المركز الاول
على نتفليكس السعوديه من وقت طرحه ومن ضمن
المراكز الثلاث الاولى ضمن الاكثر مشاهده
في الامارات
مطلقه
ولا قاعده سنه ما اشتغلت
[موسيقى]
دعواتني
انا اشتغل في بورصه الكويت
هذا مكتبك والله الصراحه انا اللي شرف اني
اكون معاكم حياك الله باقوى فريق
القهوه لا تخليني ربينا
[موسيقى]
مسلسل مسلسل ناديه احمد
من بطوله روان مهدي ومن حسين ومحمد
المنصور وفيصل العميري وحسين المهدي
واخراج جاسم المهنا وكريم الشناوي وانتاج
عبد الله مشهري وبتناول قصه رائدتي اعمال
او يعني
الرجال وهو مستوحى من احداث حقيقيه خلال
حقبه الثمانينات طيب على العموم خليها
تنضم الينا نجمه العمل روان مهدي ومنى
حسين اهلا فيكم معانا منى وروان هلا فيكم
منورين
اهلا ساره النور نورك
شكلكم كده ماني متعود عليكم بهذا الشكل
الشكل اللي رجعتوا فيه للحياه العصريه
متعوده عليكم بالشكل لوكت الثمانينات
خلينا نبتدي معك يا روان خلينا نبتدي
بروان كيف كانت هذه التجربه
والله التجربه هذه نفس ما قلت بالنسبه لي
يعني هي الخطوه الاولى نحو تحقيق الحلم
يعني
لكل لي انا كفنانه كلنا والخطوه يعني يعني
جيل جديد من القصص ومن من معايير
الانتاجيه يعني
الخطوه الاولى يعني بدايه الحلم الحقيقي
اللي انا كنت اطمح له من البدايه
منى يمكن كثير ناس انصدموا انه القصه
مبنيه على احداث حقيقيه
كيف تعاملتي مع هذا الموضوع
صراحه احنا كنا دائما نبحث عن نص ورق
ثقيل وعميق
ووجود قصه حقيقيه نقدر ننفذها هذه كانت
احد احلامنا الصغيره
لانه فعلا احنا عندنا بطلات وعندنا شخصيات
مهمه جدا عاشوا في حقب كثيره لازم نسلط
عليهم الضوء يعني يحق لهم ان احنا نصلي
عليهم الضوء وبالذات لما يكونون من
الشخصيات الفعاله واللي اثبته قوه المراه
وجودها وثقافتها تقبل قديمه وحتى ليومنا
هذا يعني انتم الاثنين ما شاء الله عليكم
نجمات وامراتين يعني عاملتين في الوسط
وبرضو لا زال الوسط الفني مسيطر عليك كثير
الرجال خصوصا في مواقع القرار اذا ابتديت
معاكي يا روان السؤال لكم انتم الاثنين
لكن اذا قلت لك انه من وقت اللي فيه
الاحداث المسلسل للان ايش حسي في تغيرات
او ما حسيتي في تغيرات كثير
[موسيقى]
لا اكيد في تغيرات كثير بس انا ما عرفت
يعني مثلا كدراسه هو يعني طبيعي يعني
تغييرات كثيره لكن انا احس يعني الناس من
جيل الثمانينات او من تسعينات او حتى اول
الالفين كانوا شايفين هذا التغير جاي يعني
وكان الناس كانت قاتل ونفس ما قالت منها
ان احنا يعني
حتى في كل مكان في العالم كل ممثل ومخرج
ستوري تلور يحب
من احداث حقيقيه ينفذه لانه
يعطي
فنيه اكثر بحكم انه عنده يكون تفاصيل
ومعلومات اكثر
اللي اشوفه ان احنا اليوم المراه يعني
صارت
يعني تقدر يعني صار لها حق في التصويت مو
بس بالتصويت بعد في الترشح يعني
المناصب السياسيه الاداريه الفنيه يعني
الان انا ارى نساء في كل مكان في كل
المجالات دائما في امثله واضحه للمراه
القائده الناجحه يعني ايه هذا واضح حقيقه
واصبح يعني امر طبيعي هو يعني حتى انه
كاتبه العمل ناديه مهديته لكل امراه عامله
وكافحت وما الى ذلك منى ايش تحسي فيه فرق
او تغيير
والله شوفي القصه
[موسيقى]
تمثل المراه نفس ما قالت روان في كل وقت
وكل زمان ويمكن في كل دوله بعد اذا كانت
دول عربيه او دول غربيه احنا كان هدفنا
الوحيد انه نبي المساواه نبي
نثبت ان المراه هي لا تقل اهميه عن وجود
الرجل في مجتمعنا فهي نصفه الثاني المكمل
وهذا كان اساس القصه ان هذول المراتين حتى
لو كانوا اغمى في وقت اللي هو حقبه هذه
كانت جدا غنيه ثقافيا وسياسيا وحتى فنيا
لا تقل اهميه عن الوقت الحالي ولكن احنا
كنا نبي نوري الجمهور او نقنعه بقصه
حقيقيه انه المراه موجوده المراه موجوده
ومو بس الحين من قبل الحين هم هي موجوده
ولكن
شوي عليها صعوبات في كثره
يعني خلينا نقول انك ترى والحريم الاذكياء
والحريم الفعاله الحريم اللي يشتغلون
المراه تنزل الحين العمل لحالها حال الرجل
يمكن يتنفره ما كانت المراه عامله كانت
اغلبها ست بيت ممكن يعني لو حتى ست البيت
طبعا يعني برضو ممكن تكون يعني وظيفه هي
تعتبر صراحه يعني وظيفه كامله يعني
انا ضد اي امراه حتى لو هي كانت ربت بيت
انها تكون لازم يكون متثق بشكل عام هذا
اللي بنطحنوه في وراكي
على خلي بالك من زوزو يعني طيب
اقول لك المراه في جميع الازمنه تتوالى
نجاحاتها وهذا اللي احنا كلنا نطمح له
خلال واحده من اكثر النقاط للناس علقوا
عليها وحتى انا علقت لكم اول ما ظهرتوا
موضوع الملابس والمكياج والاشياء هذا كله
روان اكيد لاحظتي انه الناس جالسه تنشر
الاطلالات اللي طلعتي فيها والكلام هذا
كله كيف كانت التعامل مع هذا الموضوع
والحرص انه لازم تكونوا دقيقين في هذه
المرحله
[موسيقى]
انا كنت وايد اتضايق ان انا وايد اطول
اقعد على كرسي الميك اب والشعر وما احب
الميك اب والوايد
كنت وايد اتعب البنات الميك اب والشعر معي
بس حرام بس كنت احس يعني روان على الاقل
اوكي التسريحه المعوجه كانت بالعجيبه وكده
بس احس منى حظها في الميك اب هو اللي كان
اشنع يعني كنت تطلعي
الان ما حد يستخدمها اخضر وازرق
والاشترياء كله
فعلا احنا ترى حتى
طلبناهم كلهم اونلاين من امريكا لانه في
الوان معينه كنا نحتاجها حق الشخصيه
والناس ما قالت دلال احنا ما تعبنا
بالتجهيز كثر ما الفريق هو حرام اللي تعب
وجهز ورسم انه طبعا زي ما قالت روان انه
دلال هي المسؤوله كانت عن الاطلالات وطبعا
الشركه المنتجه على راسهم طبعا الاستاذ
عبد الله ابو شهري ام كفريق او هم اشتغلوا
على التفاصيل هذه وشكل الشخصيه احنا كنا
مركزين وايد انا وروان اكثر على الاداء
والحاله والد اللي بين الشخصيتين بالذات
ان احنا ما كنا نعرف بعض انا وروان فنيا
عدل ما اشتغلنا مع بعض مباشره كان هذا اول
عمل نكون يعني مع بعض حيل فالحمد لله من
من بدايه من اول ما بلشنا البروبات مع
الكوتش انا وروان على طول اندمجنا يعني
اتصدمتي لما كنت تشوفي نفسك
الازرق وكده
صراحه يعني شوفي اقول لك شغله انا بعد
عندي مشكله في الميك اب وفي الالوان
وتسريحات الشعر وكذا وكنت ساعات اقول
معقوله كانوا يحطون الالوان يعني
طيب ما بدي يعدي علينا دلوقتي يعدي علينا
بلا ما اسالكم عن بعض الانتقادات اللي
كمان جات للعمل كمان عمل بعض الناس قالوا
انكم تكلمتم بطريقه بطريقه عصرنا الان انه
مثلا تسرق الاضواء هذا التعبير ما كان
موجود مثلا ولا كده ما كانت هذه الاشياء
موجوده مثلا كوزي تفاصيل من هذا النوع
ونقطه ثانيه نقطه التدخين الكثير انه
النساء في الكويت اكيد ما كانوا بيدخنوا
كثير في هذه الحقبه
المصطلحات هذه كوزي والاستيل ذا لايت في
مجتمعات في عوائل معينه كانت دائما يدرسون
مدارس اجنبيه وحتى بره ابنائهم هذه كانت
موجوده بس كانت يعني بعوائل معينه حسب كل
عائله يعني فاحنا هذا وهذا كان مكتوب نص
يعني فهذا كان قصه حياه اصلا ناديه يعني
فهذه يعني كانت موجوده اصلا جود بمدرسه
البريطانيه فريده بالهستوري بمدرسه
البريطانيه على فكره منى درست جامعه بلندن
فاذا ما قدرت تدرس جامعه بلندن اهلها ما
قبلوا ففي تفاصيلك يعني لكن التوم انا
بالنسبه لي فريده كنت احط لها تون مال شوي
الكويتين او شويه نو اللي يعني هذا ما ذاك
الوقت اللي اللي بين القديم والعصري اللي
هني اللعب كان بالنسبه لي فريده ومنى
التدخين موضوع التدخين بما انك دخنتي اكثر
من روان في المسلسل
انا احترم وجهات النظري معه واللي ضد طبعا
الجمهور يحق لانه هو ينتقد او يحق له انه
يعجب سالفه التدخين في حد ذاته ترى هي
مشاهد محصوره في اماكن معينه لو لو ندخل
بدي مالها يعني يمكن الناس تفهم من خلالكم
ان احنا دخلنا في اوقات اول شيء نكون احنا
الاثنين مع بعض في حاله حاله الصحبه او
حاله الذكريات القديمه بين منيره وفريده
كذلك لما دشت فريده البورصه صار عندنا
مكان برايفت اللي اللي مطلع فيه حرتنا
اللي نشتكي لبعض اللي نتهاوش احنا الاثنين
اماكن التدخين كانت اماكن تخص الشخصيتين
لهذا ما هذا ما له شغل بانه الحريم
الكويتيات يدخنون ولا لا احنا حطيناها
لانه كنا سبب يطلعون في
مشاعرهم الحقيقيه بينهم بين بعض
ففي اماكن هي اللي استخدمنا فيها سجاير
بالعكس ما ما حطيناها في اماكن عامه ولا
جراه ولا ان اهانه لاي شيء بالعكس نعم او
لا في جزء ثاني
يا رب الله يسمع منك
نتمنى الله اعلم يلا احنا بنشكركم جدا على
هذه الاطلاله معنا اليوم والحقيقه انا
يعني
بس من عندي رايي الشخصي بهرتوني بالاداء
يا بنات رائع رائع رائع رائع كان ادائكم
مستوى عالي جدا صراحه كان معانا كانون
نجمتين عمل طبعا الصفقه روان مهدي ومنى
حسين شكرا لكم